now Denmark I look forward to going but
I thought that the Prime Minister
statement that it was absurd that wasn't
it was an absurd idea was nasty I
thought it was an inappropriate
statement all she had to do is say no we
wouldn't be interested but we can't
treat the United States of America the
way they treated us under President
Obama I thought it was a very not nice
way of saying something they could have
told me no this is something that's been
discussed for many years Harry Truman
had the idea of Greenland I had the idea
other people have had the idea goes back
into the early 1900's but Harry Truman
very strongly thought it was a good idea
I think it's a good idea because Denmark
is losing 700 million dollars a year
with it it doesn't do them any good but
all they had to do is say you know we'd
rather not do that or we'd rather not
talk about it
don't say what an absurd idea that is
because he's not talking to me excuse me
he's not talking to me she's talking to
the United States of America you don't
talk to the United States that way at
least under me now President Obama when
they wouldn't land let him land in the
Philippines when they treated him so
badly in so many places the Philippines
is one that comes to mind that's
different that's different they can
treat him any way they want to that's up
to him but they can't treat the United
States with a statement how absurd